And so as we start using Unreal Engine, I've just selected a third person example map from
the launcher and from the games tab as well.
You can select whichever project.
I'm not going to be using anything specific to this project, but just in case you did
want to follow along, I've launched the launcher and selected games and then third person template.
So and yours may look a little bit different depending on which Unreal Engine version you're
using as well.
It's worth noting there.
But yeah, today we're covering the actual overview of the editor, so nothing should
be changing and you can also just watch along if preferable.
So let's talk about the UI and the overall layout of Unreal Engine.
So at the top here, we've got a few different buttons you'd maybe expect with most pieces
of software.
You know, in the file menu, you've got a few save and export and options in edit.
It's useful to highlight the editor preferences and the project settings here.
If you want to change any editor functionality, you can go there, say, binding hotkeys to
certain buttons or anything like this.
And any project settings you may want to change when it talks about cooking your projects
or editing the maps or anything like this.
And then also your plugins can be accessed through here if you're downloading any external
plugins for use inside of Unreal.
On the window, if you lose any of the side windows that are found around the outside
of the screen here, they can be found from this tab.
So say we didn't have a levels tab open, for example, I could select levels and the
levels tab appears here.
I can drag and drop it around, but I can also dock it into any of the windows that I want
here.
So it's a really nice snapping system.
I generally put levels up here.
It depends if you work with levels, for example, but like I said, you can find all your windows
here and you can also find your Quixel Bridge and your marketplace here and also save certain
layouts depending on how you're editing your content.
Maybe you want a viewport configured for a certain type of project and you want to change
different layouts.
That's also found in here as well.
So I won't go through every option, but just so you know, you can scroll through those
lists and find a good overview.
This is your main toolbar here for use inside of Unreal Engine.
So you can save your map, selecting the modes.
When we talk about foliage and landscape later on, we'll be finding them in this browser
here and you can also paint meshes, fractured meshes and also do some BSP editing, which
is your binary space partition brush.
I believe that's what it stands for.
And it's just some basic brush geometry that you can use.
You can also find your animation tab here.
We can also quickly add actors to the scene, although you'll notice that we can also see
these actors here as well, but you can add things quickly here.
This is where you will start doing your blueprint visual scripting.
If that's something you need for the use inside of Unreal, you can create cinematics from
this button and I can also press play and I can jump straight into the game here and
hit escape to come back out as well.
So a few different properties for when you actually want to play the experience and then
you can also package for the different platforms that you want to package there.
On the left hand side, we've got our different tabs here.
By default, we've got our place actors selected.
So say we wanted to place a point light, we could just drag and drop this point light
across and it'd be there.
I'll just hit that delete for now.
Some of these actors you'll use frequently.
You've got specific tabs just for lights or basic shapes that you want to drag in.
So if you want a cube, again, it comes with some basic functionality, cinematics, visual
effects, geometry, et cetera.
So a lot of this content can be found that you're placing in the maps here.
Now in terms of your either starter content or content that you're importing directly
inside of Unreal, they can be found in the content browser or the content drawer.
I'm going to find the content drawer now because it's a nice little shortcut inside of UE5.
So I'm going to press control and space bar and it pops up this drawer here, which is
a really nice functionality.
So this is essentially your content browser.
You can find all the content that you've imported here.
So if you did click starter content, for example, you'll probably see all this content.
And if we went to say props, I can double click that folder and I can find a chair,
for example, and place the chair in the scene.
So it's a really nice quick draw to access the content.
And I'm just hitting control and space bar to find that.
You can also have your content browser here, which is pretty much looks the same as a content
drawer.
So again, you can find the window and then your content browser up here.
You can have multiple versions of your content browser as well.
So if you can't see that content browser window, you can add it from there.
But getting into the habit of hitting control and space bar to find your content drawer,
that really gives you a lot more real estate to work with, especially if you're limited
on screen space.
You can just pop it open, find the thing that you want and pop it down.
It's worth noting that that can be found inside the blueprint editor, in the material editor.
You can find this window in all the different editors, whereas the content browser is mainly
just in this viewport.
So moving over to the right hand side here, we've got our outliner, which lists every
single actor inside of this map.
So when I select the stairs, it will show the stairs that are selected.
And if I just give this a bit more real estate by scaling it down, you can see everything
is here and everything is labeled inside of subfolders.
And it's just a really nice way to organize everything that is in your scene.
And then showing the details panel here.
So because I've selected some stairs, for example, I can see the static mesh.
I'll just turn this off for now and I'll come back to this favorites thing.
So by default, you'll probably see this screen here.
So you've got transform, location, rotation, scale.
So I can move these transforms here if I wanted to and move that stairs left and right.
I'm just clicking and dragging on those values.
I've just hit undo to undo that by hitting control and C.
But you can see the material that's been assigned.
And essentially, the details panel will give you a good overview of everything that is
in the properties that pertain to this specific actor.
So if I select the character, for example, the character will have different properties,
although some common like the transforms, they'll have different properties pertaining
to that specific actor.
So the details panel is a really nice way to access anything you want to configure per
actor.
Then just coming back to this favorites tab here, it's a really nice feature of Unreal
where you can see there's hundreds of options given on different actors.
And sometimes you just use the same same property by default all the time.
So when I selected the stairs, I favorited the static mesh and the cache shadow properties,
for example.
I don't currently have anything favorited for my character.
So I'm just going to select my character.
You'll see there's nothing in my favorites tab right now.
Say I want to select the skeletal mesh and right click on the skeletal mesh and add to
favorites, you'll now see that the skeletal mesh is in my favorites section.
So if I'm constantly, maybe I'm allowing cloth actors, for example, and I'll scroll
up and now it's allow cloth actors.
If I'm constantly finding details that I want to edit and I have to keep scrolling
up and down, you want to save some of that time, you can add those to your favorites.
So now that we've covered the basic editor overview, let's go into some actual content
editing and using the grid.